c'est l'une des professions les plus
sinistrées par les mesures successives
fermeture couvre-feu à 20 heures puis à
18 heures les restaurateurs en constante
adaptation se lassent pour certains au
point de jeter l éponge
un tiers d'entre eux auraient abandonné
le système de click and collect pour les
autres quelles sont les conséquences du
passage du couvre-feu à 18 heures
éléments de réponse avec aurélie renault
les photos postées sur les réseaux
sociaux quotidiennement donne l'eau à la
bouche à la lieude hier on a décidé de
poursuivre la gastronomie à emporter
karine et cyril s'adapte à ce nouvel
horaire de couvre-feu précédemment on
venait chercher sa commande jusqu'à
19h30
désormais l'équipe réorganise son
planning on a fait le choix de l'élargir
la plage horaire surtout le vendredi
entre 11h et 17h 30 je serai présente en
permanence pour accueillir le moindre
client la vente à emporter permet de
garder le lien avec les clients mais ne
représentent que 20% du chiffre
d'affaires des années précédentes
le couple a tout de même décidé de
maintenir le cap
pas question de fermer le couvre-feu va
nous faire perdre des ventes qu'on avait
aujourd'hui ça c'est certain
après on pourra pas nous reprocher à
nous même de n'avoir rien fait ni
réadapter quoi l'une des options serait
la livraison à domicile elle prend
énormément de temps
si le restaurant sans charge autre
solution passait par une plateforme de
livraison mais l'addition pour le client
grimperait en flèche ce qui vous fait
pour un ticket moyen on est à 30 euros
de tickets moyens ferait un ticket tout
avec tva incluse
ça ferait 45 euros pour le là même la
même chose le même service et
15 euros de plus pour un menu je ne
pense pas que les gens accepteraient de
payer la chose ce qui fait de ces
invendables ou après on dégrade la marge
du restaurant qui lui est déjà tendue
selon l'union locale des professionnels
de la restauration un tiers des
établissements ont préféré cesser
totalement le click and collect